welcome everyone
uh this lecture is about survival
analysis uh this is a shop we've added
to the second edition of our book
uh it's chapter 11 of the book
this is kind of a special topic but a
topic that's
more and more interest in statistical
machine learning so i think i think
you'll enjoy it
so what is survival analysis it concerns
a special kind of outcome
in which the outcome variable it's a
time until an event occurs
for example suppose we've conducted a
five-year medical study in which
patients have been treated for cancer
we want to fit a model to predict
patient survival using features we know
about the patient such as their health
measurements or the type of treatment
which so far sounds like a regression
problem which we've covered quite a bit
in the course already but there's an
important complication here some of the
patients hopefully have survived until
the end of the study such a patient's
survival time is called said to be
censored
and that causes problems doesn't it drop
if the observations are censored well it
causes a problem because sometimes the
the
as high you know 70 or 80 percent of the
patients are censored we don't want to
throw away that data that's a lot of
information
because the sort of partial information
right the fact they survived at least
five years
tells us something about the patient
about their features so we want to make
good use of that information
so we've put here some big names in the
field which we're going to cover some of
the the the techniques that they've
developed you'll hear about the
kaplan-meier curve which was developed
by the gentleman the top left in the
1959
the bottom left mantel and hansel
developed the log rank test which we'll
see as a way of comparing two
populations in survival
david cox on the top right is
responsible for the famous proportional
hazards model and actually elsewhere in
the course you'll see that trevor knight
had an interview with david in which we
asked him about the history of the paper
and survival analysis which was a lot of
fun so that module will be in in this
chapter's
videos
um along with some of the
other videos of famous people that we
have throughout the course
and the bottom right is actually
looks like a little fish out of water
because he's in color terry thurnow was
actually a classmate of
trevor and i at stanford in the 80s and
is responsible for the survival package
in our now if you knew that we put him
up here among these other giants he'd be
quite embarrassed
but we put him there because we want to
emphasize the importance of software
right software is is really has the
details of how to do something and
terry's done a very careful job of
implementing survival analysis of all
kinds in the in the survival r package
and he's done this for what 20 years or
years forever and rob you said in the
80s that can't be that's like 40 years
ago we can't have been a graduate school
40 years ago i
don't believe it either but i think it
might be true we better we're gonna have
to check up on that
okay so
now survival analysis originated largely
in medicine but there's applications in
other areas
wherever there's a censored outcome for
example suppose a company wants to model
churn
the event when customers cancel
subscription to a service
right the company might collect data on
customers over some time period to try
to figure out
which customers have the highest chance
of canceling the service
now if one does a study presumably not
all all customers have cancelled their
subscription by the end of the time
period
and for such customers that the time to
cancellation that's the event here is
censored
so
and and on that topic if if the company
can predict well who is likely to churn
they can do something right they can
call you up and maybe give you some
special offers to to keep you in if it's
a credit card or whatever
to to keep you in the in the company
so survival analysis is is a well
studied topic within statistics it's
been that way for you know 50 60 years
but it hasn't got that much attention in
the machine learning community but it is
becoming more and more popular and
important
okay so
let's get started here
so for each individual which could be a
person or a
observational unit we suppose there's a
true failure or event time
it's called failure if the event is
something if a part failing or someone
dying or maybe some other event as well
there's a true censoring time for that
individual
and the survival time it represents the
time at which the interest of the event
of interest occurs such as death
by contrast that the censoring is the
time at which the censoring occurs
for example if the patient drops out of
a study or the study ends before he or
she has the event that's the censoring
time
some notation that the true survival
time will call t
and the true censoring time we'll call c
for that individual and what you observe
is the minimum of the two right if the
failure occurs before the censoring we
get to see it
otherwise we get to only know the
censoring time and we'll call the
minimum y that's our observed survival
time
we want or that survival time is
actually a true time or whether it's
censored and the indicator delta we'll
use one
if it's a if t is less than c so it's an
actual observed failure or zero if it's
censored okay so you need to know delta
and y to really understand the nature of
the response exactly and our so our data
typically from for a training set
consists of n pairs of y and delta one
for each observation
so here's the illustration
and you can see here so there's four
patients and the solid circles are are
failures or deaths so patient three died
here patient one died here
there's actually
two different kinds of censoring here
this patient was censored because the
study ended
this patient was censored because he or
she dropped out of the study for some
reason
and these are these are both censoring
events
okay
so a closer look at centering do we have
to worry about this answering whether
it's going to buy us our analysis
suppose a number of patients drop out of
a cancer study because they're very sick
right so they drop out early
right not because they die they just
don't want to come in and be measured
and so on they just don't want to come
in maybe they've moved to a different
city to get other treatments maybe
they're too sick to come in lots of
reasons right if you don't take it into
consideration the reason they dropped
out then we'll have a bias
so the survival time will actually be
overestimated right because we'll assume
they're censored as opposed to they died
if a lot of patients were very sick
we're going to die early and we we treat
them as this regular censored then
there'd be a bias
similarly for comparing let's say males
to females
and males were more likely to drop out
of the study because they're sick
we would conclude that males survive
longer than females but in fact the male
advantage there would be to the fact
that
a lot of the sick males dropped out of
the study so we have to worry about a
bias due to censoring
how do we do that well in general we
have to assume that conditional on the
features that we observe for each
individual the event time t is
independent of the censoring time
so given the features
there's no correlation between the
actual event time and the sensory time
and the examples above that violate that
right because we said for example
someone if someone's more sick is gonna
lead them to to drop out those two
events are not independent the censoring
and their survival time and this can be
a nuisance hierarchy
i mean it's very convenient to assume
this make this assumption but you really
need to check it each time to make sure
it's okay and there's not really a way
to check it statistically typically you
want to talk to your investigators the
people who ran the study you're working
with and and and find out the reasons
why observations were censored
um so it's more of a detective search
and it's not not so statistical but one
needs to make that assumption in order
to proceed
okay so we have the survival data what
do we do with it well sorry the the
basic item one the summary one makes is
called the survival curve
survival curve is the the probability
that the true survival time is t is
greater than some fixed number t it's a
function of of time
it decreases of course because as t gets
larger the chance of surviving past t
gets lower
so for example so suppose you're
interested again the churn example
and then if t is the time until customer
cancels the subscription to the service
then
the survivor function is the probability
that a customer cancels later than time
t
right the larger the value of t the less
likely the customer will cancel before
time t
we're going to be throwing a number of
new definitions to you so
it's
there's going to be a few things you're
going to have to remember so this is one
of them
right
okay so
let's consider the brain cancer data set
which contains survival times for
patients with primary brain tumors
undergoing treatment
okay the predictors are
i've listed them there
gtv sex the diagnosis category
location of the tumor
and something called karnovsky index and
the method of of
radiation used stereo
now in this case there's 88 patients
only 53 were survived to the end of the
study
okay now suppose we want to estimate the
probability of surviving past 20 months
right
well the most obvious thing to do is to
say well let's look at the proportion of
patients who survived past 20 months
right okay this turns out to be 48 of
the patients survived past 20 months of
the 88 we're so that's 55 percent so we
might think that the survival function
at 20 is 55
the probability of surviving past 20
months
but that doesn't seem quite right
because 17 of the 40 patients didn't
survive who didn't survive were actually
censored before that time
so we're calling anyone who's censored a
death and that is very pessimistic right
so that this this probability of 55
percent is probably too low it's
probably an underestimate
right because we're treating censored
observations like like there were deaths
on conversely if we if we ignore the
censored observations and if we treat
them as survivals to the end of the
study we would overestimate the
probability so we've got to find some
way to deal with the censoring in sort
of an unbiased way
okay so this is where kaplan and maya
come in
and we're now going to present the
kaplan minecraft and interesting trevor
and i actually met paul myers member in
the biostatistics workshop in the 80s at
stanford and this paper was interesting
first of all this paper is probably the
most cited paper in all statistics in
history
but it was kind of a forced marriage
like
kaplan meyer
independently not working together uh
submitted papers on surviv on on what's
now the capitol meyer method to to jazza
the journal of the cisco american cisco
association
john tukey the editor famous
statistician himself got these two
papers and said these guys are doing the
same thing they have to write a paper
together so it's kind of a forced
marriage
they had not even worked together but
it turned out to be happy ending because
now this paper is like a fundamental
paper in statistics and survival
analysis tuki was quite an authority
only he could say things like that yes
and actually paul meyer told us he
wasn't very happy about it at the time
but
i think you know both both authors
contributed and
the result was a a blockbuster paper
so i'm just going to show the kappa
meyer estimate in pictures that the
details are in the in the textbook but
here's here's an example so i've got
five patients here
okay and the so the patient number one
died at time y one so how the kappa
meyer estimate proceeds it kind of
unfolds in time
one goes to the first failure time the
first death
and four of the five patients survive
past
y one so the the probability of
surviving past y one is estimated to be
four fifths
okay then we move on to the next failure
time notice we skipped this censoring
time because it's it's not important for
this calculation although it's going to
come in here
well there's there's three patients
remaining one two three two of the three
survive past y three so the probability
of surviving past y three is two thirds
so overall the probability of surviving
past y three is four fifths from the
first
times two thirds from the second event
so what this method does is it computes
at the conditional probability of
surviving past each failure time given
you survived up to that time
so it's a series of conditional
probabilities and we just multiply them
together right because to survive past
here you have to survive past here
that's the first hurdle and then you
have to
survive the next hurdle at y at y3
and finally y5 is the last failure
no one of the one per the only one
person made it is at risk here and zero
made it past so the probability of
of surviving past y five is zero
so the overall probability
ends up down to zero so very clever way
of taking into account the sensory and
using as much of the sensory information
as you can because they go into the
denominators of these probabilities
right so this guy he didn't get his own
estimate but he participated in the
risks in in the calculation here
he dropped out here so he didn't
participate here so the censored
observations participate as long as
they're in the study basically which
seems perfectly reasonable it's a very
simple idea but in retrospect you know
fantastic and often the best ideas are
simple and here's his result the result
in capital meyer curve
of course here we only have five
observations um three events
generally you'll have much more and
it'll be a smoother looking curve and
there there we go there's such an
example for the brain cancer data here's
the kaplan-meier curve
along with standard errors which are
gotten from something called greenwood's
formula and you can see it's a sort of
stepwise function which
and there's a little step down in each
of the the failures that occurred in
this study
so the estimated probability of 20
months from the kappa meyer is
71
which is quite a bit higher than the 55
percent which we concluded before if we
if we assume that censored observations
were deaths right
but the 71 is a much better estimate so
there's a big difference yeah right so
the kappa meyer curve is a very
important
uh summary of the data in any study in
survival analysis we'll start with the
kaplan-meier curve